[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
my name is Freddy gray and I will be
your host on the show this
week coming up on the show we will be
talking about about Chinese Espionage in
Westminster which is one of the stories
that's been bubbling away in sw1 this
week I will be talking to our assistant
editor who also looks after our
broadcasting Cindy U uh and I'll also be
joined by no less than the former Chief
of MI6 Sir Richard dear to talk about
this thrilling topic after that it's
impeachment time again uh the
Republicans have announced that they are
moving forward with an impeachment
inquiry this will be the third
impeachment in four years um I will be
talking to the lawyer American lawyer
and writer Alan
duritz about whether impeach flation is
a great problem in American
politics then I will be talking to
another American Samuel Mo an academic
at Yale about our cover piece this week
which is by Boris Johnson no less uh
who's made a quite a big intervention in
the debate on Ukraine once again as is
his want uh and he has been saying what
the hell are we waiting for um in terms
of giving assistance Aid and weaponry to
Ukraine um Samuel Mo disagrees with the
thesis uh we will be discussing
that and uh whisper it quietly but we
are going to be talking about ndas
that's nondisclosure agreements or
confidentiality Clauses as they are also
known I'll be talking to Zelda Perkins
and Maria Miller about that very
secretive subject and lastly Wales uh a
rather sad end to the show I'm afraid
Wales are dying um in increasing numbers
and there's a bit of a mystery as to why
that is I won't give it any any spoilers
away uh but I will be talking to Matt
Ridley uh the biologist and author of
various books about that um slightly odd
subject but before we get going your
usual reminder that you must subscribe
to spectator TV we've just hit 300,000
subscribers uh but we expect to get
millions and I mean Millions more um so
join The Horde um and click the
Subscribe button on your screen to make
sure that you get every episode and if
you click the Bell icon as well you'll
actually get a reminder of every episode
so be sure to do that as
well let's begin with allegations of
Espionage in Westminster which is the
rather juicy story that broke this
weekend uh in the Press about uh a
westminster's Chinese agent as he was
called in the Press which is a young man
um who was arrested back in March along
with another young man uh and we don't
uh know much more other than the fact
that they have not been charged and the
young man in question the man who's been
called westminster's Chinese agent has
denied that he has spied for
China to talk about this I'm joined by
Cindy Yu who is our broadcast editor and
host of our Chinese Whispers podcast uh
and also by no less than Sir Richard
dear love who is the former Chief of MI
6 Cindy I'll start with you because
you've written a piece in the magazine
which has as far as I'm concerned a very
amusing opening uh about what it was
like to see your face uh in the national
press in a
picture uh with the alleged uh spy uh
for China um and I suppose I should
start with the obvious question which is
are you now or have you ever been an
agent of the Chinese Communist
party uh no Freddy I haven't been and I
am not at the moment either although of
course spies would say that wouldn't
they um this picture was um in the
papers as you say on Sunday and on
Monday and it is me with this uh alleged
spy at a panel in Westminster in
Parliament um earlier this year we were
actually ironically enough doing a panel
called defeating the dictators um you
know as you know from my role reporting
on China you know I often get invited to
those kind of Westminster um discussions
so I didn't know him from a professional
capacity um and I also write uh in my
piece as well that actually sometimes we
went for a drink um and the last time I
saw him we actually ended up at a
friend's flat and played some code names
which for viewers who don't know is a
board game based on Espionage where
rival spy Masters race to Rondevu with
their field agents and me and this
alleged spy um actually smashed the
other team but I didn't realize until
the news of his Aras came out over the
weekend that actually hadn't heard from
him for 6 months um and now it's pretty
clear uh why not yes so Richard Let Let
Me Tell to you uh I mean it's talked
about everybody who's ever had an
intelligent Source or everybody known
anyone who's ever talked to an
intelligence Source uh seems to have
known that there is a lot of Chinese
Espionage in Britain uh I think the
general view is that we've been quite
compromised for a long time uh is that
your sense
well I think that the Chinese
intelligence machine let's call it that
has been pretty active in the UK but I
think you need to make some distinctions
about what this activity consists of
because you know what they might do in
Parliament is rather different from what
they might do to steal intellectual
property or you know other activities in
which we know they engage age and I
there's no question that as China has
risen uh as a regional and then Global
power uh their various agencies have
become much more aggressive much more
active than they used to be and they are
let's say a feature of the global
Espionage scene if one could call it
that yes Cindy I think that's uh
something people find difficult to
distinguish here because there was some
talk over the weekend about how uh
it appears that Chinese influence let's
say has infiltrated seemingly sinos
skeptic groups um are we really talking
about influence pedaling here which is
not exactly the same as
Espionage well this is the tricky thing
we don't really know what the young men
in question have been accused of other
than spying for China um the reporting
around it um the times has gone the
furthest of anyone has said that
materials were exchanged information was
exchange but it wasn't classified
although it was sensitive so Richard
might know more than me about where that
line is drawn um it could be that if you
are someone who is in Parliament you
know the kind of Gossip the things that
people talk about in the corridors who's
up Who's down uh and those might be the
sorts of things that uh China is very
interested in uh where you know in the
best case scenario or the most
charitable understanding the people
being accused didn't realize uh what
kind of information they were sharing um
of course as you say on the other end
there is Espionage now we do we simply
don't know and no charges have been
brought and until they are brought we
probably won't know exactly what is
going on here um but you know the The
Wider question of what is influence and
what is interference I think is really
really important you know we have to
have China um in the world I mean it's
it's not going anywhere uh Chinese
people will be here Chinese businesses
will be here uh Chinese uh all sorts of
companies and politicians would come and
visit so where where is the line being
drawn um and where is it okay to have
influence where is it uh Co interference
and I think that you know that is a
really really tricky question and I
think that's one that the UK you know
for the first time in a long time China
is rising at a time when the UK doesn't
feel as strong as China so these are the
questions that we're grappling with
really so Richard we often talk about
entering a new Cold War era with China
and so on and I think what perhaps uh
electrified uh certainly the media
impact to little extend the Public's
imagination about this story is that uh
this it was a British a white British
man uh not someone who like Cindy as
being racially discriminated against uh
and accused of being a fire just because
she happens to be Chinese uh this is a
British man and it has sort of Echoes of
uh the spy stories that we all know and
are thrilled by from the cold war of you
know Kim philby Anthony Burgess of of
actual
treasonous uh brittish activity um of
people who are want to help China more
than they care about their
country yeah well I think this needs
really some
explanation um and the first little
basic point is that the new security uh
National Security Act if that's
precisely what it's called has
changed um you know the legislative
position now in the past to be
prosecuted under the official Secrets
act you would have needed to have
divulged to a foreign power uh
classified secret information and you
know the the terms were were very clear
were very limited were very precise the
National Security Act has introduced a
broader um offense and that is to be uh
an undisclosed agent of a foreign power
and it's copying legislation which has
been in force uh for a long time in the
United States you know whereas if you're
acting as a lobbyist around Congress or
the Senate if you're doing it secretly
on behalf of foreign power you're
breaking the law simly in
Australia and you know this um reform is
long overdue because look the way that
intelligence Services
behave is you know they cultivate
people uh and and cultivations have all
sorts of purposes it may be simply to
Target other people who the cultiv may
know who might be vulnerable to
recruitment um you know
they infiltrating themselves into your
circles into your lifestyle and
obviously Parliament is of great
interest of foreign intelligence
services and to be of interest in a
foreign intelligence service you don't
necessarily need to know anything Secret
at all you just need to know a lot of
people and need to be
networking uh and you know all of that
ancillary information is the stuff of
you know
basic what spies would call targeting
and and and case
development I think in this particular
case I mean what's interesting is that
the young man's protesting his innocence
and doing it very vifer usly and it
suggests to me that the agency he's been
talking to or receiving money from or or
whatever is probably not uh one of the
two conventional spy agencies of the
Chinese which is military intelligence
that's the second people's Liberation
Army or the more powerful civilian
organization internally and externally
which is the ministry of State security
but there is a third
organization which is massively
important huge and has lots of money
which is part of the Communist Party in
China which is the united front work
department and its specific role is to
as it
were take down the sort of effectiveness
of bodies criticizing China or or to
sort of render them less powerful less
influential and at the same time to
strongly promote the interests of the
Chinese Communist party and the Chinese
uh party leadership I mean the original
purpose of the works um of this
department which which has this rather
bizarre name was actually
to undermine and knock out other
political parties in China and around
China at the time of the Communist
Revolution and the party fed this
department fell into disarray but was
has been revived re relatively recently
and given a lot of power and it's really
part of XI
jinping's um you know Machinery of
government and Machinery of
international influence my my guess is
with this young man protesting that he's
innocent is that he's sort of fallen
into the clutches of this department I
think that this man probably has been uh
rather stupid and
naive and you know his
networking May well have been financed
by Chinese money in which case it's
broken the law but people are suggesting
that his offense predates the
legislation so it may not be possible to
prosecute him yeah
um so I I don't know what I think is
rather bizarre about this whole event is
it happened back in March um and it's
only recently been announced um and that
suggests to me that the announcement um
I I mean probably his offense predates
this legislation unless there's
something much more serious which is a
conventional
recruitment yes Umi which is possible by
let's say the ministry of State security
or to
pla well cdy uh you've said uh in your
piece that you couldn't believe that
somebody would be so stupid uh do you
think there's an element of that going
on you you talked to a lot of people in
sort of you know the Chinese community
and Westminster expertise areas or
experts about China in Westminster do
you think a lot of people are um sort of
really useful idiots perhaps uh for
China because they don't they're not
been aware of the fact that they are
effectively uh propagating a Chinese
message um they just think they're
having an interesting conversation and
debunking Western narratives and so on
yeah Freddy I mean I'm sure you're right
I've definitely seen people um around
the English language uh discourse around
China repeating parting lines from
Chinese propaganda things about how you
know people in sang are just one happy
family uh or that they're just
vocational schools uh or
people being Hong Kong you know all
sorts of things they definitely do get
pared and you do kind of wonder about
the motives of some people but I think
the wider question and the debate that
this has triggered this whole story has
triggered this week is about how should
we understand China because some of the
reaction to this story has been that
anyone who calls for a more
sophisticated approach to China as this
alleged spy did do uh is seen with an
ulterior motive but I think that's wrong
because in an open Society we should
look at the merits of an argument on
their own regardless of who's saying it
now obviously it's different if someone
is being paid by a foreign state or or
coerced by a foreign state to do
something like that but that doesn't
mean that the arguments that they're
raising or that arguments that Sim
people similar to them are raising are
not worth listening to and you know for
for me this is quite a personal uh
question Freddy as you know because
Chinese Whispers my podcast tries to do
this we try to make our understanding of
China more complex more sophisticated
it's a big country with a long history
and so I think the takeaway from all of
this is not that anyone who says hold on
a minute China is not just this big bad
there's more to it than that is
necessarily um a useful idiot as you put
it but actually there is a need for more
understanding of China especially at
this current moment so Richard finally
do you think uh since the pandemic
perhaps where a lot of hostility uh
towards China was was felt and and
perhaps in many ways rightly so uh do
you think think and that our suspicion
of the Chinese Communist party is
causing a kind of Reds under the bed uh
mentality uh in Britain now towards
China uh and Chinese people in
Britain well to an extent yes I mean I
think what's happened is we've suddenly
woken up to the fact that China you know
can be a pretty unfriendly partner and
an aggressive partner but on the other
hand I really use the word partner
because our links with China are so
close um I just read in my papers today
and I'm quite heavily involved in
administration of universities that you
know 30 some 30% of PhD students in
science in the UK at the moment to
Chinese Nationals I mean the statistics
are just
mindboggling now in a way that's good um
you know China is a rising power an
important power it's done a huge amount
to lift its population out of global
poverty you must you know you must look
at China and understand its
achievements but you know there are
aspects of XI jinping's regime which are
very distasteful very unpleasant very
aggressive but you know to visit that
character on whole Chinese people seems
to be absolutely
ridiculous um the other thing you know
we've woken up to is the Chinese are
very active in intelligence collection
and Espionage and let's face it this
country has been hugely naive about that
not the professionals I'm afraid people
like me have been shouting loudly from
the side cles for a long time and I was
one of the first people to you know
really object strongly to the whole
Huawei uh attempt you know to be the
contractor for our 5G and thank God the
government's changed its policy on that
what we really need to do is to have a
much more realistic and eyes open
relationship with China and I'm not
suggesting that we cut our links with
them that you know we treat them as a
pariah we can't I mean our economies are
intertwined but we've got to make the
Chinese understand that we are as it
were prepared to take a tough line with
them when it's necessary and you know we
have a very good model for this who are
far more dependent on China economic
than we are which is Australia I mean
Australia's been having this problem
with China for years um particularly in
their parli mentary system and you know
they they've taken a very very firm
stand they've been punished for it
economically not massively but you know
in marginal Industries the Chinese have
stopped buying Australian Goods but
overall the Chinese are self-interested
and they haven't as it completely
undermined their economic relationship
with Australia because it's too
important um and I I think we've just
got to wake up I the problem that we've
got is that you know if you go back to
Cameron and Osborne when when when you
know they were uh running the government
as it were or running relations with
China they were hugely naive about China
I mean there was two very young people
in my opinion who had no idea what they
were dealing with and didn't talk to
people like me and they should have done
if they would would have done they
wouldn't have liked what I'd said to
them at all um and you know they led us
down a path and they led a lot of
British businessmen down the same path
we've just got to be much more realistic
but I'm not suggesting in any manner at
all that we cut our dialogue with the
Chinese we just got to have a very clear
open relationship with them and they
will respect us for treating them
exactly like they treat us reciprocity
is the
answer very good thank you very much uh
Sir Richard and thank you
Cindy now let's turn our attention to
America where this week the house
Speaker the Republican house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy has announced that uh
Congress will be launching an
impeachment inquiry into Joe Biden over
his links or possible cooperation with
Hunter Biden his son's dodgy business
dealings with foreign entities it's a
very murky topic and the Republicans
have been digging at it for some time
however pushing on towards an
impeachment is a significant move and
could change the story
entirely I'm joined Now by Alan duritz
who is the lawyer as well as the author
of get
Trump and Alan I thought by I'd say
start by asking you um there's quite a
few commentators who are already saying
that this is a big mistake from the
Republicans at least from a political
point of view do you agree with them I
think so I think they're making the same
mistake the Democrats made when they
tried to impeach president Trump twice
on grounds that were not acceptable in
the Constitution there's no basis in the
Constitution for impeaching a president
who has quote created a culture of
corruption which is what McCarthy said
about him he has to have committed
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors I don't even think he has
enough Republicans at this point to
bring about a vote in the house he's
just setting out the members of the
committee to investigate it's designed
largely for internal political purposes
congressmen uh uh of from Florida and
other places have threaten the
leadership of McCarthy unless he moves
against Biden so this is a poit iCal
decision it will backfire in the same
way I think that the Republicans uh had
made it backfire against the Democrats
uh when Trump was impeached I predicted
this when I defended president Trump on
the floor of the Senate I predicted that
the uh uh Republicans would do the same
thing tit forat and it's wrong when
either side does it and Nei side should
be allowed to weaponize and distort the
Constitution well I think we should talk
about that next but it struck me that
the timing
is quite bad uh for the Republicans in
that Joe Biden has just been uh on a
international trip he went to Hanoi and
delivered a very embarrassing speech
where he didn't seem to know where he
was uh there was a CNN poll out last
week that showed him uh performing very
very badly um with the American public I
think
75% of Americans are seriously concerned
about his mental and physical health as
um what the Republicans seem to have
done though now is perhaps changed uh
the narrative and flipped the script at
precisely the time um when the Electoral
calculus seem to be settling in their
favor both sides are doing that both
sides are scrambling the Electoral
calculus the Democrats are trying to
indict president uh former president
Trump that try to remove him under the
14th amendment that too distorts the
Constitution both sides are trying to
use the Constitution to improve their
electoral Chan and I think in both cases
they may actually uh backfire I think
what you were getting at earlier Alan is
uh this idea of impeach
flation uh was meant to be a emergency
mechanism um in the US Constitution is
now being uh
cheapened uh since we've had this is now
the third um impeachment inquiry in four
years um and that it's ties into exactly
what wor Americans most about their
politics which is that um it's
completely dysfunctional um and it's
just two sides uh using legal mechanisms
and all sorts of dirty tricks against
each other um and that the political
system is
broken uh is that not the real problem
here yes in fact James Madison the
father of the Constitution said that
misusing impeachment would turn the
United States into Great Britain uh
because in Great Britain it's very easy
to get rid of the Prime Minister just a
vote of lack of confidence uh as we have
seen over the years and the US
Presidency was supposed to be stronger
and more enduring than the Prime
ministership in any parliamentary
country and so Madison rejected the
concept of impeaching a president for
Mal Administration or for doing the
kinds of things that the uh Republicans
now claim that President Trump uh uh
President Biden has been doing and that
and the Democrats claim that President
Trump was doing um Great Britain is a
great country but uh we have a different
method of riding ourselves of the chief
executive than uh Great Britain does
lasty Allen I don't know if you've seen
this slightly eccentric story uh about
the libertarian party which is actually
America's third largest political party
uh and they've applied to put Joe Biden
and uh Senate minority leader Mitch
McConnell um who's 81 Biden is 80 um
under a conservatorship uh because they
feel that the the elites are too
geriatric to be trusted with running
America um it's obviously a bit of a
stunt uh but first with your legal hat
on do you think it's actually
feasible no no we we do have a
geriatric uh we have too many old people
in too many high positions of uh Power
um we need more young people in politics
but the answer to that is not some kind
of a mechanism for uh for changing the
election system if you don't like who is
the leader Your Leader vote against them
I'm going to vote against Donald Trump
for the third time many people will vote
against Biden uh for the second time
that's the method of removal in the
United States none of them have
committed impeachable or removable
offenses Alan dtz uh author of get Trump
thank you very much for joining us thank
you now on the cover of this week
spectator magaz Boris Johnson the former
prime minister has intervened again in
the debate on Ukraine uh and he has
written to urge the British government
um to help Ukraine more what the hell
are we waiting for he says we should be
supporting Ukraine now uh in ways that
we perhaps didn't realize we should have
done before uh with as much hardware and
as much kit and as much material support
and financial backing as as we can I'm
joined Now by Samuel Mo who is a
professor at Yale Samuel I'll start by
asking a very simple question you've
read Boris Johnson's piece what did you
make of
it well it's very rhetorical but in the
end it engages in you know crash
speculation that just more of the same
even more money even more Weaponry will
change the equation uh and there's an
overstatement of you know just you know
how much Ukraine's achieved W with what
we've given them so far combined with
just a a leap into the dark uh about
what it could achieve if we just gave
them more and that's not an argument
it's just blind hope more more blind
hope when it's not
working well uh as uh Boris does say in
the peace I mean he makes a fairly good
case that the wall uh hasn't gone
according to plan to Vladimir Putin uh
Russia occupies a lot less of Ukraine
than it did uh the counter offensive he
concedes the Ukrainian counter offensive
he concedes hasn't been going very well
but is making some
progress uh do you think perhaps you're
being a little too cynical um of the
argument um that Ukraine can win the
war uh I'm I'm I'm avoiding engaging in
any speculation about what could happen
I do think we need to look back to
decide how hopeful we ought to be now
that the equation can be changed it's of
course true that Putin has performed
dreadfully his generals have uh you know
lost the war from its opening days and
yet uh within a couple of months the
battle lines had basically stabilized
long before the counter offensive with
the exception of the events last summer
in April through uh July of
20122 um when you know K
fell basically Russia's controlled the
same Eastern territory with some minor
modifications uh and that's a Quagmire
that's an an the kind of endless war it
took my country 20 years to concede it
had lost in Afghanistan and finally
leave even though serial promises were
made that more Weaponry surges of troops
and material would change the equation
and didn't so Boris Johnson was there uh
in power in Ukraine in uh in April when
basically the battle lines had
stabilized and he
insisted uh to zalinski that peace
options not be pursued and yet all this
time later with all the loss of blood
and treasure we're in approximately the
same place so on the basis of that
background trumpeting the counter
offensive for what it can do in the
future seems Hollow seems not to match
the experience we've actually had of the
war
today well uh boris's argument is that
uh we by allowing Putin to win any
ground um inside Ukraine we would be
conceding that it's okay for uh an
orthograph power to attack a sovereign
country what do you make of that
point I think it's very serious of
course precedents are Set uh and you
know arguments about appeasement uh and
its consequences go very far back in the
history of your country and the history
of world politics in consequence
meanwhile at Munich misguided Statesmen
were lulled into believing that Hitler
would cage his
Stormtroopers as far as I can see there
actually has to be a realistic
option uh of an
alternative and in spite of my country
going as far as illegally sending CL
cluster
Munitions to Aid in the counter
offensive there does not appear to be
such an option and that's where uh the
former prime minister's piece gets very
long on rhetoric and short on detail in
fact uh there are some weapon system
mentioned that zalinski is now asking
for but he of course asked for cluster
Munitions too got them and has received
a lot of
gifts uh of the the the highest Tech
Weaponry available to the most advanced
armies in world history and
yet though Putin's lost the war he's
been relatively Ed in in holding the
ground he holds so that's the reality
and I I would think we need to give a
little bit more attention to what it
would mean to stare it in the face
rather than hope against hope that it
can be changed through some you know new
means do you think you talk a lot about
rhetoric there do you think um a lot of
that rhetoric is because uh of a perhaps
unconscious awareness of the fact we are
uh the west and and Ukraine and Russia
are in a sort of stalemate situation do
you think it might be to do with the
fact uh that you could have a different
president um in America uh quite soon
you could have different leaders ships
um all over Europe quite soon um and
that the time for uh making some final
push in Ukraine uh is running
out I think that's very insightful I
mean it's been clear for some time that
Western policy makers understand that
the window is clothing closing not just
because of the fearful possibility that
Donald Trump could return to the
presidency seems likelier every day but
also
because that the exhaust of Western
publics uh has long since set in their
attention is strayed it's very difficult
to muster the political legitimacy for
more war funding uh especially given the
blight uh at home that that money could
have addressed including in the United
Kingdom so uh it it it it is absolutely
right that this seems for those who want
to take a last chance another bite at
the Apple to take it now but the
question for them is why haven't they
already had their last chance to change
the equation which many of us hope to
see and yet it hasn't happened uh Boris
Johnson uh finally Samuel Boris Johnson
uh of course is a big San of Winston
Churchill um it's quite possible that he
sees himself as a churchillian figure uh
and of course Winston church was very
hot on
rhetoric uh and I think it's fair to say
although there is some academic dispute
about it um history did vindicate him to
some extent uh on that front with World
War II um who's to say that you are
right uh and that Boris Johnson's uh
rhetoric about the danger of uh
autocracy and authoritarianism is wrong
nothing and I want to be very clear on
that that I'm
indicting uh the former prime
ministers uh overconfidence without
taking a confidence stand myself I can't
prove that uh this war will remain a
quagmire that it is indefinitely it just
seems like there's reason to believe it
but I think we've seen so many times
since
Churchill lived including when he
returned as prime minister in the midst
of decolonization
when the a moment of appeasement and the
moment of defending the British Isles
against Nazi AGG aggression just were
used as a false
analogy to justify endless Wars and uh
you know military quagmires and this
looks again to be one of those instances
and so could it could could could
Johnson be right that we can summon
Churchill's ghost at again for the right
moment absolutely but he's likely wrong
because it's been done so many times yes
with the predictable outcome uh and I
know I said finally last time but I'd
like to make this one finally you talked
ear about the quagar of Afghanistan and
Iraq um I suppose perhaps that could be
the wrong analogy to use from a western
perspective because of course this is
Putin's potentially Quagmire not our
because he is the Invader well it's but
but it's not it's it's not as if one has
to choose one or the other it's clearly
Putin's Quagmire but it would also seem
to be Ukraine's and ours collectively
and the West uh in providing assistance
for what looks to be a a a war of
basically stable position and so there's
no reason to choose it's absolutely true
to emphasize how Grievous a mistake from
his own perspective Putin clearly made
uh and the situation in which he finds
himself but that doesn't eliminate the
realities of our situation in opposing
him Sam Bo thank you very much for
joining us on spectator TV thank
you we have an interesting piece in the
magazine this week from Daisy iith uh
who has written about her experience at
ITN which of course uh broadcasts
Channel 4 channel 5 and
ITV uh and she's talked about being uh
effectively gagged by a non-disclosure
agreement and is ask asking the
questions why won't ITN release many of
its ex staff from these agreements I'm
joined Now by Maria Miller who is the MP
and former culture secretary and by
Zelda Perkins who is co-founder of
ungagged can't bu my silence which is a
group campaigning against uh the overuse
of non-disclosure agreements and Maria
I'll start with you because you've
brought this up in Parliament um why do
you think this is such a pressing issue
and why are you bring it up
now well in Parliament we passed laws to
try and make the country uh work better
one of the areas of legislation we have
is to protect victims of discrimination
at work and if non-disclosure agreements
are used uh to cover up allegations of
discrimination at work in effect they're
Sil they're potentially silencing people
and speaking out when they suffered
something that could well be against the
law now INE in theory that should not be
the case non-disclosure agreements
should never be used to cover up
criminal wrongdoing um but in essence
they've become seen as an industry
standard by many employers and are
effectively
silencing uh victims of wrongdoing and
that's just not right it's it's actually
against the rule of law Zelda you've
been campaigning about this uh for some
time do you think we're about to turn a
corner here do you think we're about to
to to come to a realization that ndas
have become far too
widespread uh and need to be clamped
down
on I hope so I mean we're turning
incrementally round a corner in fact
this year the government
legislated to prohibit the EAS of ndas
in higher education between staff
students and visiting speakers so they
have actually acknowledge the fact that
using ndas to cover up misconduct and
that includes discrimination bullying
sexual harassment anything of that form
they've acknowledged that that's wrong
so that's a great step that's the first
law of its kind actually in the UK and
that is protecting millions of students
now and hundreds of Staff thousands of
Staff but unfortunately we still have
the rest of the economic Workforce
vulnerable to being silenced by
non-disclosure agreements I think one of
the biggest problems is that since the
word or the acronym NDA has become more
exposed ironically people are actually
um in a more dangerous position because
employers and HR departments and lawyers
are now no longer using the word NDA
they are just putting into settlement
agreements it's a standard settlement
agreement it has a confidentiality
clause or it's a non-disparagement
clause or it's just standard settlement
and there's a big difference between an
NDA and a settlement there's no
difference between an NDA and a
confidentiality Clause Yes actually
that's what I wanted to ask about to
what extent are ndas or confidentiality
Clauses actually enforceable when it
comes to issues that don't relate to the
immediate business interests of the
client for instance uh let's say sort of
a culture of sexual harassment in the
office are NDA actually legally
enforcable well that has to be tested
but essentially the majority of them
would not be enforcable if they were put
in front of a judge however the
likelihood of of a vulnerable victim
having the money or psychological or
emotional wherewithal to take this
agreement and test it in court is very
very unlikely and that's the gamble that
employers take um with with a private
contract I mean for instance with mine I
was not even allowed to hold a copy of
it so I couldn't test it um and one of
most of the Clauses say that you're not
allowed to speak about its existence so
if you can't speak about its existence
how can you get a second opinion to find
if it's legally enforceable um they're
really a tool of threat and abuse and
continue the abuse that the victim has
possibly suffered at the beginning and
make it more traumatic in the long run
yes Maria I think that's the point isn't
it perhaps that it's not so much that we
need a a legal change or a piece of
legislation so much as uh people just
need to be more aware of the fact that
they can't necessarily be held to Ransom
by scary-looking contractual agreements
that they may have signed well we've
already been there haven't we with
people um being required to be given
professional legal advice before they
sign redundancy agreements uh the truth
is uh that uh for too many years
uh lawyers were part of the problem as
well uh the SR and others The Bar
Council um are now really alerting their
members to the misuse of non-disclosure
agreements but unfortunately very very
many of these sorts of severance
agreements so we're talking here where
somebody's left employment uh and you
know that there are allegations which
there may well have been a payment uh to
to to form an agreement uh and then you
know confidentiality is the price that's
paid um so many of the people drawing
these up are not lawyers they are maybe
not even HR professionals and what I'm
finding when I raise these issues with
industry is that they plead that it's an
industrial Norm these are you know there
there is settlement agreements that are
used across industry um and clearly it's
being normalized that these sorts of
secrecy cles in there if they are
enforceable or not is can only be tested
in the CL in the courts and of course
the the the the employees who are
affected will be risking potentially
having to pay back maybe thousands of
pounds of severance pay um if they were
found to have been in breach of their
non-disclosure agreement and that's a
price that most people simply can't
afford to pay well allow me to play uh
devil Devil's ad advocate for a moment
um I mean if you sign an agreement uh to
accept money on the condition of not
saying something and then you do say
something is it not uh fair that you
repay the money that you've agreed to
take for not saying something well if
you have say been subject to maternity
discrimination or maybe discrimination
because you're a disabled person the
fact that you've left that job because
of uh allegations in those areas will
probably put you in a position to take
an employer to an employment tribunal
and you would have been eligible for
some sort of payment um so the notion
that um but the employer clearly will
not give you a financial settlement uh
avoiding them the embarrassment of going
to an employment tribunal uh without uh
a secrecy uh clause in that agreement um
now that person's an invidious position
isn't aren't they you know do they
particularly if they're a young one
maybe who's just come back into the
workplace uh got a small child have they
got the money to go to an employment
Contra uh tribunal or would it be easier
to take that money which maybe they due
quite quite rightly um and sign a
secrecy agreement as part of the pece
maybe feeling that they have very little
choice but to do that so I think in
reality uh people are often doing this
because they are very vulnerable people
in the first place disabled small
children um and they are forgoing their
right to go to an employment tribunal
which may well be a much more uous thing
for them to do anyway so um in theory
you're right but I think in practice uh
individuals would have been due some
payment uh of course uh if their
allegations the true but I I find in in
the most part most people don't want to
Le their jobs because they're making
false accusations I'm itching to add to
that because it's really interesting the
way that you presented that question
because actually the way you presented
that question is the Crux of the problem
what you asked was if you've been paid
some money to keep quiet and then you
speak isn't there something wrong there
the point is is that at no point should
you be being paid money to be silent
about abuse or discrimination you are
being paid money as
compensation for agreed harm or agree an
agreed fact that you can't solve or
resolve the issue at work you are
agreeing to not take this further
legally that's what a settlement
agreement is about and that is perfectly
reasonable and there are often cases
where it's he said she said she said she
said he said he said and nobody can
agree and there's no proof and so we
can't tell if it's right or wrong so the
two parties will agree to settle that
settlement money is for the damages and
it is to not or it is not to take the
case further legally it is not to not
speak about a trauma that has happened
to you now I think Maria will back me up
here is that it is the statistics in
terms of people who make vexatious
claims and want to go to the press to
talk about what has happened to them are
minimal the reason that people are now
going to the Press every week it seems
with with you know scandals and and
breaking their ndas and speaking about
toxic work Environ environments is
because they are desperate because they
have been silenced because their life
has been altered Forever by this instead
of it being uh incident that is then
dealt with correctly and everybody walks
away in the correct way what happens is
is they're silence they are not allowed
to speak to they're not allowed to go to
group therapy they're not allowed to
speak to their husband or their wife or
their therapist or certainly in my case
I was not allowed to speak to the hmrc
or the police without getting further um
permission from from you know my
aggressor lawyers which isn't enforcable
and isn't correct but it was to me now
when people become desperate that's when
they go to the Press when they've asked
to do something the correct way when
they've asked for help where they have
may be whistle blown but settling
is not about being paid for silence
those two things are are ex are
exclusive of each other Mar I mean uh
Daisy I and her piece talks about ITN uh
I think you mentioned uh ITN is it the
case that once a story starts to break
ITN has had a bad year PR wise I think
it's fair to say um that suddenly
there's a kind of pylon and that may be
because a lot of people suddenly feel
free to speak or it may be a broader
sense that a lot of people now think
that uh ITN is now you're allowed to
attack idn which one is it okay so I
think non-disclosure agreements
silencing Agreements are a problem
across all sectors of Industry they're
seen as an industry standard Clause that
you put in there um and you know in many
ways not really thinking about the harm
that you're causing so I don't think
there's any one sector that's
particularly uh got the strangle hold on
this problem it's across the board uh
certainly I've been approached by people
in in different areas um I have been
approached by people who have worked for
um ITN News Channel 4 Newsroom Channel 5
Newsroom and so certainly in the debate
I mentioned that uh not mentioning the
names of the people involved because
that is a very much a knive case and the
notion that that has been resolved is
not correct and I think that we've also
got to be prepared to hold people to
account for what they're saying and uh
certainly when it comes to news outlets
whether it's the spectator or others
perhaps we have to hold you to us a
higher standard because you are there to
provide facts for people to um to
understand current events so maybe they
do have to be held to a higher standard
yeah well absolutely no NDA is at The
Spectator as far as I'm aware um Zelda
uh uh could you just tell us a little
bit about because it's obviously a
bigger story than just ITN and it's a
matter of public interest let's
emphasize that uh are other companies do
you think thanks to your work are other
companies are maybe even bigger
companies than ITN now looking
to look at their the way they get
contracts signed when people leave the
company trying to adjust the way they
behave uh in an employment law
sense well I can certainly tell you that
from the work that I've been been doing
um in the last two years this affects
every single sector and no one sector is
worse than another to be honest um and
this is as Maria was saying is because
it has become a industry standard
essentially and I think people um have
been scrambling to keep their
reputation um more you know protected
more importantly than their own staff um
and this often comes comes down to
financial gain but interestingly if you
have a healthy Workforce and you are
looking after your staff you are going
to be a higher performing company and
this is something that I think a lot of
companies are beginning to realize and
whether they're choosing to change their
policies for ethical reasons or for
financial reasons I don't really mind
the point is is that ndas should not be
being used they're being used abusively
as a tool to silence people
we've started at can't by my silence a
voluntary pledge for businesses in all
sectors to sign up to agree to not use
non-disclosure agreements for the wrong
in the wrong areas to only use them for
protection of internation in
intellectual property and Trade Secrets
which is the appropriate place for their
use now this pledge is what what we did
with the universities and it actually
really helped push the legislative
change and it's been very interesting
for me approaching big businesses from
um big tech companies to High Street
Banks to law firms um to see their
response to signing up to a pledge that
is purely saying they will not use them
internally with their staff um I'm
having to work quite hard but it's very
clear which companies are moving forward
and want to be seen to move forward the
other important thing about this pledge
is that it's not retrospective we
understand that nearly every sector uses
and has used ndas we're not out to get
people and you know this is an
opportunity for companies to step
forward go okay we've had the wrong way
of dealing with with misconduct in the
past and we want to move forward um and
this is a great opportunity and this is
a great opportunity this was a great
opportunity for ITN to lead to lead and
show that they understand that in the
past this is something that has been
used regularly and that they want to
make a change and that they want their
staff to be looked after now I can tell
you if you released all of the your past
staff from ndas um of your own valtion
it's very unlikely that they then go
running to the Press they would just
want to be able to know that they were
free to speak to their friends and
family if they chose to if you keep
holding these people gagged I'm afraid
this is what happens um with an article
exposing the misuse of of of of gagging
orders you know in a in a newspaper in a
magazine
uh Maria if we assume that uh sunlight
is the best disinfectant do you think uh
as a principle it has to appli to the um
employee and the employer equally in
that uh if there is a dispute after
someone has uh left their contract the
employer should be just as free to say
what happened with the employee as the
employee is with the
employer well we already have really
clear laws on defamation so if an
employer an employee fall out uh that
they come to an agreement that an
individual is going to leave there may
even be a payment in hand the likelihood
of even uh of either of those parties
wanting to talk about it publicly I
think is quite slim the employee because
frankly they'll want to move on um and
the employer because they don't want to
have their uh perhaps their dirty Lenin
Washton public so I think the reality is
that people will just move forward the
important issue the uh victim those they
don't feel as if they can't seek help um
and that they can't explain to a future
employer why they may have left the
employe of their previous uh their
previous job at the moment there are
people who've got gaps in their CVS
maybe um you know leaving employment not
able to say why it's creating problems
that I think are very unnecessary our
defamation walls are there if people do
start to speak out in a way which is
unto
uh and untruthful uh so we should use
the law as it exists at the moment to
protect against uh that sort of
unwarranted uh nastiness after an uh
somebody lose their job Maria and Zelda
thank you very much for speaking out on
spectator
TV thank you I should add uh that
because we do uh things properly at The
Spectator um we did approach ITN um to
come on the show um and they have given
us a statement instead um which strongly
rejects uh what it says are the
historical allegations being made about
the culture in itm newsrooms by a former
employee it an ITN spokesperson said ITN
is committed to an inclusive transparent
and respectful culture and we reject
entirely the suggestion that this
historical allegation was not fairly and
thoroughly investigated 3 years ago
we have a duty of care to all
individuals involved in any workplace
dispute and therefore it would be
inappropriate to comment on specific
circumstances since April
2022 ITN no longer routinely uses
confidentiality Clauses in settlement
agreements so there we
go let's turn our attention to the
environment and ask the question why are
so many whales dying this year 71 whales
have washed up on the shore of shores of
New England and neighboring states in
the United States of America uh and the
rise in uh Wales uh arriving dead on
shores uh has coincided with the
expansion and increase of wind turbines
and the wind farm
industry um to discuss this I'm joined
by Matt Ridley the biologist and auth of
viral the search for the origins of coid
um and he's written a piece about it in
this week's spectator Matt um first off
why are all these whales dying do we
know at
all we're not sure why they're dying it
could be natural causes it could be
collisions with ships um and it could be
something to do with the wind industry
that this is the the question that needs
to be looked at the so the sonar survey
vessels that go out in the area to
prepare for wind FS make a lot of
banging noises um for hours and hours
and hours on end uh these are extremely
loud uh possibly louder than they should
be According to some recent research and
they might both confuse or distress uh
the whales and they might separate
mothers from carves and the carves might
then Die For example so that's the
accusation as it were that it needs to
be looked into as to whether or not the
whales are dying because of this uh
because of the coincidence between an
increase in whale deaths and an increase
in Wind Farm activity now it's not
proven but it's a possibility that needs
to be looked at and what's curious as
you say in your piece is that uh a lot
large parts of the environmental
environmentalist movement particularly
Green Peace are not very interested in
exploring uh this particular question
probably because um as far as they're
concerned wind turbines equals good um
and therefore if they could be doing
harm um to Wales they don't want to
explore it is that
right yes my attention was caught by a
tweet from Green Peace uh telling
someone off for linking Wind Farm uh
expansion to whale death saying no no
it's definitely not that um there's no
evidence for that uh and therefore we
should ignore it now the Curious Thing
here is that Greenpeace has been a
champion for a very long time of
something called the precautionary
principle which is that you'd never say
we haven't got evidence for something
therefore it must be all right you say
the opposite if we haven't got evidence
for something then we must immediately
assume it's guilty until we know more
that's been their raise on Detra and of
course Green Peace began as a save the
Wales organization 4050 years ago um so
uh it's a bit ironic to see them rushing
to the defense of Big Bad Business um uh
and rushing to rubbish even a suspicion
that there might be uh a cause of whale
deaths here um but as you say the
problem with much of the environmental
movement Greenpeace included uh is that
uh as well as counting its enormous
riches it spends its time uh cozying up
to the renewable energy industry these
days who are conc seen as a good thing
and not as a bad thing so uh I'm just
trying to see whether or not um Green
Peace should be abandoning the
precautionary principle for the first
time in respect of whales deaths uh and
again as you point out uh they would
never um have been so cautious about um
suggesting let's say genetically
modified crops which is I know some of
you have written a lot about uh they
would never been so cautious as as to
sort of disabuse people of the idea that
genetically modified crops might be
dangerous correct green pieace has
campaigned long and hard against one
genetically modified crop in particular
called Golden rice which is a vitamin A
enhanced rice uh with with a extra Gene
from a different plant in it uh and
which uh can make a miraculous
difference to the death rate of um kids
in very very poor cities in the
developing world who rely on Rice as
their staple food um but for 20 years
Greenpeace has been the main opponent of
this technology saying we don't know
that it's safe sure there's no evidence
of harm but we don't know that it's safe
well suddenly they're saying there's no
evidence at harm so the wind industry is
safe that's a double
standard it does appear to be a double
standard I wonder if you've have you had
any feedback from Greenpeace in your
inquiries uh no not I've not had any
detailed but I have followed what
they're saying on so social media and as
I say they're sticking to the line uh
that the wind farms can't be the cause
of the death of
Wales not we'll leave it there but thank
you very much indeed for coming on to
spectator TV that's a very
intriguing that's it for this week uh
thank you very much for watching
spectator TV I hope you've enjoyed it
all uh a quick reminder do subscribe to
our spectator YouTube channel um 300,000
and growing fast um and by the time I
see you again I fully expect us to be at
400 or 500,000 at least thank you again
goodbye
[Music]